[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey
[Music]
[Music]
hey
hey babe hey babe look at this well
we're doing it we're doing it
so you have never had a pork chop
never and that's what this is here that
is what it is okay
i've also never had goat cheese just
goat cheese on the plate
and you yes have never had a cinnabon
look at this bang we have
a mild it's actually it's warm a warm
cinnabon
okay which we were told by the chef we
said hey she said hey listen stupid
you told me not to eat this up everybody
said we've got to start the show on the
show
the chef had an attitude if i'm being
honest now listen this is out of the
this is an
authentic cinnabon it's just in tin foil
because we put it in the
mic authentic cinnabon from carvel on
86th street in brooklyn shout out
shut up um so i'm gonna now take a bite
for the first time in my life
yes of a pork chop and goat cheese now
let me ask you something
yeah cause the chef first of all the
chef is unbelievable phenomenal food
yes we think 800 calories on this whole
plate so i'm well within my real food
we're guessing i wonder what my favorite
calories are telling me though
when i cut into this yeah i won't
there'll be no maggots and when i eat it
maggots won't explode in my stomach from
the larva and the pork
yeah right so how maggots are coming to
pass
okay is flies turn into maggots right so
once flies go into your meat and then
they have sex with each other they have
babies the babies are
maggots something like that i'm not
exactly sure it's not going to happen in
the pork chop because that's what we
said on the one episode that's right
everybody got mad because we didn't know
and they told us maggots come from flies
got it okay all right i'm gonna do this
i'm so excited for you
because there's only one first pork chop
right now let me
okay is there a bone in here or is it
there is a bone but it plays like a
steak you know you can
eat around the bone all right let me die
right all right i'm like genuinely
yes get in there nice wow i mean hold on
okay here we go i mean first of all this
thing cuts like butter is that
is this your favorite thing to eat so
wait i'm checking right now i love
a grilled pork chop it's unbelievable
what do you think about it there's a
nice char on that some nice spices
right nice and now you're saying that
spice that's not larvae that's no it's
not it's not gonna be a maggot maggots
come from flies they've brought there
when they bring
their bread they bring that extra
baggage with them
but delivers from evil man
take your time you might have got some
fat on the edge
if i'm being a hundred percent honest
with you i'm being
this is genuine this is genuinely i'm
genuinely dead serious i'm about to say
right now
maybe the best thing i've ever eaten in
my entire life
i swear to god that may be
like i almost feel like i've been
i've turned my back on an entire
food i've been trying to tell you it's
just so good
this is like truly like butter like
do they always do like that or is that
just the chef just understand there's
many different ways this is prepared a
certain way okay
now i have to go inside there's some
okay so now can you eat raw pork is that
okay to eat a raw
okay so dude i got to be honest with you
i mean
dude i i isn't
it's good right i mean
wow you've been missing out poor yeah i
mean that's not really how they're
eating but you know it is what it is you
know
i mean you got a little smudge here
that's one of the best things i've ever
eaten in my what's the sauce on what is
it is it just the pork is so good
pork is it doesn't look appetizing but
it is right it's the rub is unbelievable
isn't it
just a nice grilled pork i see how lean
the meat is
and tender and tasty it's bursting with
taste
so how do they make bacon out of this i
don't know any of that stuff
it's a different part of the pig though
look at you really made a mess
yeah so so what do you think now what do
you think you could you could have been
eating pork chops this whole time
i regret i fully 1000 regret
not ever tasting a pork chop in my life
even if it is going to turn into maggots
and larvae which i still kind of am
convinced it is
in my stomach i'll just have a long day
in the bathroom tomorrow and i'll come
back the next day and eat a second pork
chop
it's almost worth the maggots it's worth
the maggots now now the goat cheese is
next
different different thing so this you
have it in a salad
but maybe you want to get in a nice
chunk and just eat it this is it's i
gotta be honest with you this is
grossing me out to have to eat the goat
cheese
really the pork chop was so appetizing
and good this i gotta be honest with you
like
i'm skeeving this right a lot of people
don't just eat a chunk of goat cheese on
its own
i you know you have it here mixed into a
salad you have some complimentary
flavors with it so should i eat it with
the salad do you think we got i think
it's wrong both i think you eat it raw
first all right let's do it let's do it
i mean really
no no really you're having that bad
reaction
you're gonna wash that down with pinot
grigio
i can't do it really really it's that
bad i can't what's in here
apples i can't do it
it's that big no what are you doing oh
that's crazy oh you look barbaric
the ghost is just you you have to i
can't i can't look at you like this i'm
gonna start dry evening
i can't look at it i'm still driving i
hate the goat cheese you have a whole
you have to wipe your mouth down and
wipe your hands
it's it's it's too much no dude that
the goat cheese smell disgusting wait a
second now i sound like derosa hold on
hold on
no if you went to rojo you would say
something outlandish like yeah
goat cheese is not available in 40
states
yeah so i got to be honest i think the
goat cheese is delicious
delicious it's just creamy
it's so good the salad and the apples
fantastic the goat cheese literally dude
i almost threw up that goat that was
that was a real reaction i can't deal
with the goat cheese i never want to eat
goat cheese again
i'm actually done with goats are you
serious i don't want to do anything from
goats anymore get yourself an apple and
a walnut on the fork
and have it with everything walnuts is
another thing i'm new to
i can't ever do the goat cheese again i
literally the goat
the goat cheeses are hard if the goat
cheese is a hard no
the pork chop is i could probably eat i
would eat your pork chop if it was
cooked to the right temperature yeah
yeah mine you could die from a pork chop
was the best i'm
i'm being dead serious maybe that's why
i think the goat cheese is so bad
because the pork chop was so good so i
was expecting to have
balls blown off again because the pork
chop is life changing and then the goat
cheese is
reconfirming why i never had goat cheese
in my life i don't like goat cheese
you're blowing me away
with your disdain for the goat cheese i
feel like it's this creamy delicious
elevated elevating ingredient thinking
about a goat
just thinking about it and the cheese is
really i mean the goats have
they have cheap chin hair yeah what
you're doing now is you're trying you're
thinking of a goat as a whole while you
eat a salad
i'll if this pork chop was growing out
of the side of a pig i'd eat it off the
side of a living pig
right the goat cheese it's it's it's a
disgusting thing
it's i never want to have the goat
cheese again but but this the apple
salad and whatever this is i mean
compliments to the chef
this is the puree potato puree i mean i
feel like a newborn baby right here
i love the puree
i'm good
oh my gosh it's outrageous i mean the
chef
this puree is outrageous chef i love
this i love this
the puree i'm talking about the puree is
delicious i feel like an infant
wow oh i just got some goat cheese in
the puree
i gotta be honest i think he's being a
little over the top
because he's that he's he's literally
almost throwing up
wow i guess you know people don't like
it
i guess he's one of those people wow
i know i know you shouldn't be focusing
on goats as a whole when you eat it i
think that's the issue
look you got water all over your limbs
on my lulus goat cheese
i'm gonna look into the camera right now
and i'm gonna tell you guys
exactly what i mean every word of this
i would rather be beheaded by isis than
never have to eat goat cheese again
don't put that out there bring it on
i would honestly if honestly the
situation he described
i'm just call me what you will i'd
rather have goat cheese
literally if you ever had me in a
hostage situation where i had government
secrets the
uh you i would give them up in a second
if the if the
if the interrogator just put a little
bit of goat cheese on my lip if he just
had a little spoon
and said tell me everything i'd say no
no what if you had to let go cheese like
off of a goat cheese
off a goat's like beard like you put the
goat cheese on the goat and you just
said go right up to the goat
no no i'd rather i'd rather
yeah what if it was called are you
getting thrown off by the words goat and
cheese put together and it's goat cheese
what if it was called something like
special cream or something i don't know
well it's like uh you know whatever it
is it had its own name
i think go me thinking of a goat
it's making me don't make that face i
swear to god because i'm that guy i'm
the guy i have a weak constitution
so you ever see that scene from stand by
me when somebody throws up and somebody
else throws up and they're only in
blueberry pies and then everyone's
throwing up you just did a dry heave and
everything in me i felt about to dry
heave myself well it's
one of those things where the goat
cheese was so disgusting to me i
immediately felt it in my butt
you ever get like a chill would you feel
it right in your butthole i felt the
goat cheese right in my butthole
immediately right with the porkchop i
fell to my penis which is a different
feeling
it's one's good one's bad where do you
feel the pinot grish the pinot grigio
you've got goat cheese all over your
wine
i can't do it i can't do it you ate it
so slob there's like remnants of goat
cheese everywhere
i'm just gonna have to do this
you're gonna have to finish that entire
bottle
see what i really have to say at
patreon.com
[Laughter]
porkchop is is a delightful delectable
treat that you've been missing out on
it's one of those things where like
again trying to like
you know you know cut calories and not
eat bread i was always like all i could
ever really eat is salmon and chicken
because i don't really eat too much red
meat i'm like salmon chicken
now i'm gonna eat this it's lean now
pork chop if i see if i see a pork chop
the only thing is because the chef is
such a great chef
the only thing that i'm considering is
maybe
the chef did you know some tricks of the
trade
and made the pork chop taste even better
if i go and order it from a restaurant
it won't have the chef's touch it's
because you're gonna have to take it
that's amazing the goat cheese though
can go for yourself all right i'm done
with sal
i'm done with goats no dude that's wild
if you ever made me
go cheese again i swear to god i put
every corner of every pillow directly at
you
[Laughter]
it'd be like a laser beam of pillows
corners
anywhere near you don't do it i don't if
we go to a petting zoo i'm skipping the
goats
i can't believe it what do you what are
you watching i don't know goat cheese
goat cheese is disgusting wow yeah i'm
not a goat cheese person and
goats themselves are kind of like
satanic to me yes maybe that's what it
is they're satanic animal
i feel like i'm eating the cheese of
satan
[Laughter]
but i think on the road we should go to
the worst restaurant in a small town and
have you order the pork chop there
oh yeah i'm sorry goat cheese is
unbelievable all right
now we do have a dessert component which
this is mind-blowing if you haven't seen
the previous episodes
we talked about i never had goat cheese
or a pork chop which we thought was
crazy
even crazier to me sal has never in his
life he grew up in the united states of
america
has never had a cinnabon no it's not
like you grew up in uzbekistan
you grew up in the united states of
america in the state of new york the
metropolis of potentially the world
you never had a cinnabon you never had a
cinny no i never had a city and i can't
believe that that's a bit as big a deal
as you're making it is it really that i
mean what's the bigger deal pimp what do
you think the bigger deal is
me not having pork chop or goat cheese
or or cinnabon well
you should tweet this out we're on taste
buds
but a pork chop is from is a is a dish
that's been around
for thousands of years at samurai right
but uh cinnabon
is like uh you know last 20 30 years so
it's like i feel like it's crazier that
you haven't had a pork chop what do you
think
what do you think pimp knowing that you
dabble in marijuana i'm
very surprised you haven't had a
cinnabon i know but also dabbles in cbd
sunday scariest.com
promo code hey babe that's what it is
and here we go all right so here we go
so
so cut it well yeah you want to cut it
yeah or
cut it well um i think the chef gave us
uh
oh she here she chef gave us a cinnabon
knife yeah
boom now by the way keep in mind sits
dry
one cinnabon 880 cows babe
one city 880 no yes
oh my god how do you what do you do i
mean you just gotta go
you gotta just you gotta log out of your
myfitnesspal it's like eating a big mac
or something
it's it's what it is okay okay you ready
yeah here let's see
here here pull pull your side okay oh
wow it's dense
yeah it's dead and it's gooey and the
thing is it gets layers upon layers
so you see it opens up like an onion the
cinnabon's like a like a manufactured
onion
when you eat an ants there's more goo
more cinnamon so this isn't goat cheese
this is cinnagoo
frosting then the inside it's like it's
like a strudel it's it's um it's the
best i think thing that america's ever
made and i'm not sure if it's made in
america you you but this is
this is bad for you look at that look it
on the bottom yeah yeah look at that
there's all sorts of uh caramelization
going on there
you got yourself a nice cream yeah
layers
okay i could smell it i don't know i
could
i get i can guess by the smell what this
is going to taste like i've had pastry
before i've had cinnamon i've had icing
but but you never had you've never had
it all together you've never had a man
you've never had a united states
chemical induced cinnabon absolutely not
yeah okay
all right
oh my god oh my god
you've never had anything like that sal
be honest with me
wow never had anything like that wow i'm
getting waves of flavor
i mean that cinnamon is it almost feels
like i'm it was a stick of big red
yeah you're also going to get waves of
feeling light-headed because your sugar
is through the roof yeah i mean that
icing what is that dude it's not goat
cheese
oh my god the icing is outrageous let me
see
whoa wow wow wow
this must sound good over the airwaves
um
so this is like that amsr stuff right oh
yeah
do you see just it's sitting up on that
is it am i getting that right amsr
cinnabon
wow i mean
there's something going on in there
that's not going on at a glance
like something in the middle there
that's happening it gets to be a gooey
treat that really comes together a
little thing the spanish call
asuka baby yeah they're finding ways to
load more and more sugar
into that puppy wow the cinnabon the goo
a fresh
hot cinnabon at the airport i don't care
if the plane crashed i'd be happy yeah
i can imagine it coming right out of the
oven but you can't
you i think if you eat one of these
alone your whole day has to be rerouted
and you start your day off with one of
those you can't eat again until the
next week you're gonna you you can't
have one of these how often can you have
a cinnabon
no i mean that okay i'll be honest with
you i used to when i was christy
cinnabun's called
oh yeah you ate your cinnabon oh it's
gone your whole half is gone
so i could have eaten two cinnabons by
the time you ate a half wow
no i love cinnabons the cinnabon cereal
fantastic
so the cinnabon um um uh
it's it's one of those things where it's
so
good and and it's got so many calories
like i think eight or nine hundred in
one cinnabon
that you just have to kind of accept
accept it yeah it's like
it's we're doing it we're doing it yeah
and you let go a cinnabon is good
for a person who's who's wants who says
to themselves i'm going to start to get
back in shape
and go back to the gym when i hit rock
bottom if you want to go quickly to rock
bottom with your weight
cinnabon's the answer what's the most
have you ever had more than one cinnabon
sal are you kidding me oh my god really
my cholesterol cholesterol's 270 my
blood pressure's 170 over 110.
i used to be 250 pounds babe have i had
one cinnabon you ready for about to tell
you
no yes what my dad what
i used to do come on dude not daily but
what i've done
many times in my life is on the same
sitting
gotten two cinnabons from the carvel on
86th street and then walked up two
three blocks to nono's pizza and got an
entire zucchini slice pie
and i've eaten five or six zucchini
slices back to back wash them down with
two cinnabuns and they also have
here's the other thing i got you a big
cinnabun they also have the mini
cinnabon packs and they also have
cinnamon bun
just the inside of it like cinnamon bun
rolls with dip with the little icy
frosting dip i didn't even get you extra
icing
normally what i do is i'll take a bite
of a cinnabon and i'll do a shot of the
frosting no so and and
what do you feel like after that i feel
like i need to go to the hospital and i
usually do right
oh yeah no dude if you you're telling me
you put down one cinnabon and then
you're looking at another one you're
like i'm gonna have another cinnabon i
gotta be honest with you
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna do it but i
could i'm talking about
in 30 seconds devour like a chihuahua
yeah you know when you give a dog a
treat
yeah yeah that's what i could do with
the center chihuahua a chihuahua
chihuahua what am i what am i saying
well you said i got chihuahua
what is it chihuahua chihuahua
i don't know if it's a chihuahua it's a
what am i saying wrong
well i think it's chihuahua chihuahua
chihuahua and i'm saying chihuahua
chihuahua
chihuahua a chihuahua no no not
chihuahua
chihuahua chihuahua
chihuahua but why are you saying wawa
wow wow chew
chew voiwa like wawa chihuahua
chihuahua yeah what am i saying what am
i saying
chihuahua a chihuahua
i think it's wah not wow so you you're
you're you're
going wow and you're also going wow so
you've seen a chihuahua
a
it's named after prominence in mexico
the chihuahua province is it
yeah right i didn't know that i don't
know chihuahua
chihuahua it's not chihuahua though it's
chihuahua
chew i could be wrong chihuahua yeah
what do you say dachshund or dash house
chihuahua dachshund
dachshund me too why people say darshan
people say dash and dumb like what are
you [ __ ] a german in the german
military
modern day america wiener dog is that it
wiener dog
how do you say it you put it
she's saying how you're saying it yeah
she's saying chihuahua she's saying it
that you're right
chihuahua chihuahua chihuahua
chihuahua
wow spell it chihuahua
c-h-i h-u-a-h-u-a
chihuahua c tell me if i'm right c-h-i
h-u-a h-u-a chu
h i h u a h u a pronounced chihuahua
so then why are you saying chi wow
chihuahua
because i'm using the common dialect of
the mexican people
why chihuahua is pronounced
why is chihuahua pronounced chihuahua
and not
chia huhu it's saying chihuahua
chihuahua
first let's try a simple conference and
say the second pronunciation out loud
now say the first pronunciation out loud
chihuahua
notice how your mouth takes the same
shape for wawa sounds for both
there is no way to say who ah without
making the w
sound that is wha
chihuahua okay
chihuahua chihuahua are bisexual
that's not from this even that's old
yeah but
you guys know that right now we met a
week ago by the way not to not to say
but god bless tom brady yes tom brady
thank god one
super bowl 43 year old guy oldest guy in
the nfl yeah anymore
and uh and also you know listen because
you know kids it's not all about winning
and losing
it's it's what you do with the thing and
what you do with the game and i just
want to give a quick shout out to the
kids
chiefs coming in second place patrick
mahomes doing fantastic
down there kid sitting yeah um uh yeah
i want to pause this so we were just
leaning back let's pause it dude how
about this you know my girlfriend's
pregnant
yes literally in the middle of the night
last night i wake up
it's 2 30 in the morning i smell cookies
being baked
and i because because it was the middle
of the night
i didn't know what was happening bottled
by this fresh baked smell
so i wake up i start to smell what i
thought in my head even though it was
cookies i thought i was smelling burning
toast
so i wake up i look in the ceiling i go
stroke i thought i was having a stroke
so i was like stroke and then i go over
to touch her
and be like you know and she's not there
so then i start to get nervous i'm like
what happened like did somebody kidnap
my family and it's like baking cookies
then i'm thinking is it is the house
burning down but again pregnant fresh
baked cooks
2 30 a.m 2 30 am pregnancy cravings did
you
wake up and eat any yes really
but here's what i did 230 yes because
you have to with a couple of comments
yeah well you have to because here's the
thing pregnancy
she's going through a craving she
doesn't want to be baking cookies and
eating fistfuls of cookie dough you're
[ __ ] supportive but she's like it's
the baby so i'm like listen i'll support
you know listen your boobs are growing
because of the milk my boobs are growing
because the cookies
the bottom line is we both got big tits
right right so
so so and we're just gonna have to deal
with this you know whatever it is right
so i i started eating the cookies with
the almond milk
and it was one of those things where
again pregnancy cravings pregnancy
emotions i just found myself
five minutes before that i was asleep
having a wonderful dream
just enjoying my sleep now it's just i
was probably 2 37
you're fully awake i'm fully awake
eating cookies fresh out of the oven
consoling my pregnant girlfriend who's
crying for no reason dripping tears into
the cookies no reason why she's crying
she just started hysterical crying bacon
cookies eating cookies at 2 37 in the
morning
and that's just what that's what it is
that's just what it is when when a
woman's pregnant
is you just have like when she was
pregnant with her first child i came
home one day
and she had her hand one hand in a jar
of nutella
one hand in a jar of mustard and she was
eating bite for bites oh
no i come in because i had a long enough
shows
i come in and i say what are you doing
and she goes
what are you doing and i was like
i'm coming home from work right and she
was like is this funny to you
and i was like no i mean the jokes i was
doing a couple hours ago i guess were
pretty funny
and she goes you're sleeping on the
couch wow i swear to god
nothing and then i went to sleep on the
couch because i mean i'm not gonna deal
with that maniac
but i she was eight months pregnant at
the time i slept on the couch
she woke up i woke up two you know in
the morning because you know the
my living room is my living room and my
kitchen i woke up to the smell of fresh
made pancakes
she had made me a stack of pancakes that
were unbelievable
do you think a guy has ever told a woman
you're sleeping on the couch
no have you ever would you even think i
tried it once
i tried you tried to tell a female
you're out get on the couch
yeah and then i had to live with my dad
for six months
yeah that you know you never hear about
the guy telling the woman to sleep on
the couch no i wouldn't be able to deal
with it like if
even if even if i was there's been many
times where i'm like snoring
like at the top of my lung snoring yeah
and she'll go out on the couch
and i'll wake up and be like go in the
bed i'll sleep on the couch i can't have
it where it's like
the girl sleeping on the couch can't
it's not right you got to correct your
snoring though
i know i do got a correct try to you get
you got to do get an apparatus or
something it's not good for you
well there's actually an apparatus that
i saw on the internet it's called snore
balls
so this is the name of the look at
snoreballs
stop storing with these yeah snoreballs
so um
where can you scroll i just saw it
that's a tennis ball
oh it's a tennis ball there was a thing
called snore balls use a tennis ball to
improve breathing into sleep
oh okay oh you're putting it behind your
neck is that what it is yeah
yeah yeah because i used to get i used
to snore all the time and i always have
sore throats
all the time but now yeah i just haven't
knock on wood
been sick i guess because of the mass in
the purell or whatever but i get less
and less
short throat so i'm not snoring as much
but um
every time i would snore and she would
go on the couch i would just say you
know yeah like let me let's switch
positions
there's been a couple of times where
i've been i've been relegated to i
didn't want to sleep on the couch
so i just crawled in bed and slept with
my daughter where i would just sleep in
my daughter's bed which is
i best frightening for her when she
wakes up and she's like who is this
beast of a man in my bed
yeah let me what do you what's your take
on eating food in bed
eating food in bed yeah like do you have
a make a sandwich and then like you're
already watching tv from bed then you
just go sit
prop up yourself in bed with a pillow
sit up right watch tv and have yourself
a soup
or a breakfast in bed or a sandwich or a
dinner every dinner and bed or is that
some people think it's it's like a like
it's off the table not even an option
disgusting
to eat in your bed where you lay if
crumbs get in the bed if they think
about it
it's unhygienic bed bugs are you like f
that here's what i'm gonna tell you
salmonella yeah which is a great
nickname for yourself salmonella
sal minella yeah well i just had real
pork we'll see what happens
well we'll see fingers crossed if by the
way if you do have to go to the
emergency room tonight we will be still
be continuing the podcast
live from the gtr and we'll be doing ad
reads live from the r if if sal volcano
gets salmonella that's a that's a
promise
um do you pose that question to every
food in bed
food in bed i would say true story
i would say three to five times a month
maybe a little bit less since i've been
trying to watch what i eat but three to
five i'll say three times a month
i wake up in the morning with crumbs in
my belly button from eating in bed
really so i'll
co i'll consistently have a crumb of my
belly button there was a couple of times
where i found a full m m in the belly
button which is nice to wake up to
because you start the day off with some
nice candy wow so you eating better but
you know what you know what i never
really
did per se but then i started when i
started working on the road and
going away this month like a lot of
times in a hotel room
yeah you know you don't have necessarily
a place to eat other than the bed
yeah my daughter eats in the bed
constantly i mean when i
literally when i like sometimes my
daughter i'll go wake my daughter for
school
there's been multiple times i've found a
skittle in her ear you know cause she'll
have skittles like
she'll hoard food yeah she's scurrying
to bed with
rice treats in her socks who gets right
who gets crumbs in their socks
she'll have rice krispies treat crumbs
in her socks how does she do that i
don't know because she's eating in bed
and somehow the food just winds up in
her feet
it's ridiculous how i can't tell you how
many times and i don't know how this
happens you know you'll be giving her a
bath to be scrubbing her butt you open
up her butt cheeks describing bought
food
oh come on is that true you'll see kids
that's really true
kids get food in the craziest places
[Laughter]
i had an m m stuck on my nose show on
abc yeah i'll never forget
kids get food in the craziest places my
mother was getting her hair done at
europa
in ridgewood queen shout out europa
shout out europe sitting down getting
her hair done
she gives me a quarter to go over to the
to the you know machine where you would
put a quarter in and then turn the knob
yeah
and eminems would come i have one of
those downstairs yeah yeah i got an m
m a peanut m m which is a jumbo n m i
put it stuck it up my nose because i was
seven years old
got the eminem got the peanut m m was so
lodged in my nose they had to call the
fire department
and a firefighter who has to actually do
real emergencies had to now sit me down
on his lap
and and get this like little metal
scraping tool and he
and he got it up in my nose and then he
pulled it out of my nose and because i
was just
maybe just so nervous or whatever it
popped out onto my shirt where i was
sitting
and i picked it up out of my shirt and
ate it
you should have tried to like crush them
we couldn't crush the chocolate we
couldn't and my mother is just a nervous
person we got nervous and we called
9-1-1 and they were like
they showed up and they were like what's
the emergency and we're like oh this
kid's got an m
m p a peanut m m stuck up his nose oh my
god but they said the whole fire truck
and everything
listen when it comes to paying off debt
it can often feel like an uphill battle
high interest rates resulting in minimum
monthly payments keep you in an
endless cycle of debt upstart can help
you get ahead my
barney rubble really needs this my dad
needs this this kid's always in debt
instead of asking me for money he can
use upstart
so here it goes find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today when
you go to upstart.com
hey babe that's upstart.com
hey babe don't forget to use our url to
let them know we sent you
here's what it is unlike other lenders
upstart looks at more than just your
credit score
like your income and employment history
so a lot of you guys
have jobs out there that listen to this
podcast a lot of you don't
so we'll see what upstart decides to do
this means they offer smarter rates with
trusted partners
with a five minute online rate check you
can see your rate up front
for loans between 1 000 to 50 000
50 000 do you dread looking at your
credit card statement every month i do i
don't even look at it half the time i'm
just like yeah i probably have money and
then the card gets declined
and i'm like i guess i don't have money
listen we don't blame you
upstart can lift that weight right off
your shoulders that can finally feel the
relief of being
free of credit card debt okay that's
what we want to be is free of credit
card debt
that's the goal and upstart's going to
get you there just go to upstart.com
hey babe that's upstart.com
h-e-y-b-a-b-e and your
debt's going to get cleared and they're
going to do the five-minute online rate
check
and it's just gonna be nice and i'm
gonna send this to my father
listen everybody knows me i'm chrissy
the wino i love pinot grige
i like to get a little crazy bright
sellers let me talk to you guys about
bright sellers
this is a wine service that helps you
find wines
you love while making wine more
accessible to everyone so
bright sellers comes on in and it just
it hooks you up with the wine you want
you know you've been drinking wine for
years
bryce tellers pairs you with unique
wines using their crazy
accurate algorithm everybody's about the
algorithm now everybody's about tapping
into the database
even wine companies are doing it that's
why bright sellers is on top
because they use all the new data and
they compare you
they compare you up to six wines that
fit your taste profile you just take
their 30 second quiz
let the wine magic happen and boom they
pair you with the wines
i mean dude i mean i'm looking for an
alternative to pinot grigio i got to use
this because
you know pinot grigio after a while just
starts to all taste the same
and i like you know obviously i love
italian men but maybe i want some french
bread in my life maybe i want a little
baguette in the throat
for our babes we are giving you 50 off
50
off your first six bottles from bright
sellers okay that's a lot of money
that's a very good deal
all you got to do is go to
brightsellers.com
hey babe that's bright sellers
c-e-l-l-a-r-s
dot com slash hay babe so once again
bright sellers
b r i g h t c e
l l a r s dot com slash hey babe
fifty percent off your first six bottle
order one more time that's
brightsellers.com
50 off your first order let's drink some
white together let's get drunk
let's text our exes one of the last
times i remember really
so i ordered i was i was on the road and
i came back
and i was like really tired right and i
ordered uh
room service you ever i had a per diem
but i had to spend
yes i've been i've been on the
i've been in the room service with you
and you
you you're a fun room service guy yeah
you go apps entrees and desserts
a variety a hundred percent yes they're
literally it's like i feel like the
[ __ ] king louie of france
when i go hurry on the road there's
nothing to look forward to nothing i'm
watching
extra for seven hours straight it's me
and mario lopez nobody else
i know dude you know what's so funny
somebody tweeted at me once i forgot
when we had went on the road a couple
years ago like
oh you and sal must have so much fun on
the road you must just take over that
town and i'm like we immediately go back
to the hotel room after every show
smoke sativia every type of cbd and get
apps
entrees and desserts in the hotel room
and we watch movies
on from sal's playstation that he
brought yeah that's it that that's
genuinely all we do that's all i do
i don't think we've went out and we've
been you know invited i don't i don't
know that i've run out to one
bar ever ever we always have a nice
lunch we go to
we go to an antique store we do the
shows and we go back to the hotel room
that's our life
and i love it i actually love it it's
nobody we do life shopping
yeah a nice lunch maybe hit up a candle
store
i've never been in a town with sal where
we've walked past an antique store that
we haven't went into it's almost like
if we don't go into the antique store
i'm like sal you mad at me
listen do yourself a favor go into the
go taking you got the best candles in
the game
i love the candles too i i know what i
turned over a new leaf i want
candles burning in my home at all times
100 you know i have this thing with
candles when i buy them right
sometimes they're like you know you can
you can get cheap candles you can get
reasonably priced candles
right go for it wow what do you think
you look like john f kennedy really yeah
amazing yeah you look like you look like
someone from that time or at least you
look like kevin costner
in japan jfk you can't see you don't got
bad vision
is does this mean i have bad vision
because i'm seeing clear i am seeing
crystal clear that you have food in your
beard
oh i do oh it just went away do i really
no you got to tell me these things
i can only see because of their glasses
i i never seen you right now you really
look like
kevin costner is it a good look or a bad
look what are we doing no it's
distinguished
i'm getting a whole vibe from you that
i've never got before so should i do
this
wow what should we do wow take a picture
of me with the glasses pimp let's see
what the what's you you do because they
are glasses that are like reminiscent of
the 19 like
30s 40s 50s let me see
what do we think my eyes are closed do
one more
let's see you look you look i tell you
that's a whole different
mood for you let's see
there you go you look distinguished if
you were telling me about history in
those i believe even more
that's right so you want to ask me a
history question yeah i mean
i'll never forget where were you the
first time you saw jfk and found out jfk
was shot
um where was i i think i was in second
grade my teacher mrs link
um told us that that uh that jfk had
just been shot
right
you're not doing retina damage right now
no i feel fine
you see me clearly well you know for the
longest time i thought
jfk i i got their
deaths mixed up i thought jfk died in a
plane crash and jfk junior got shot in
dallas
but it's really jfk got shot in dallas
junior died in the plane crash yes
rock hudson got into a plane crash too
uh didn't he die of aids
didn't work out tonight out of a plane
like one of the first celebrities to
openly say he has aids i think so but i
don't think he died from aids i thought
he died from a plane crash you don't
know if the p could have survived the
plane
north aids was a contributing factor
right
in his sleep for mates why did i think
he died in a plane crash
yeah was rock hudson ever in a plane
crash if you
died if you die of a plane crash if
you're in a plane crash and you also
have aids god's wants you dead
god doesn't want you alive at all you
gotta
ships are being stacked where it's like
someone's trying to tell you something
yeah i gave you aids and put you to
playgrounds yeah it's over i also have
weirdest food
stuff that's common up here put ice
cubes and cereal i've done that before
never in my life why would you ever put
ice cubes into cereal what reason what
about washing your hands with ice cubes
you ever do that
um you know if i was i'm sure that if i
was like
you know somewhere where there was no
water and there was ice and i wanted to
clean my hands off you've done that i
imagine i have but why would you put ice
cubes in cereal
just to make it a little colder
because my why'd i just pour more new
milk in it
because i usually drink almond milk and
we don't put the almond milk in the
fridge
is that bad well you need to put almond
milk in the fridge why do you have to
put almond milk in the fridge it's not
from it's
it's almonds they're not going to go bad
there's certain almond milk that you can
like
that they sell that you can keep not in
the fridge but then there's yeah almond
milk that you can
yeah but once you open it you got oh so
you just had extra in the closet
once you open it it has to go in the
fridge really i
believe it's refrigerated after opening
the carton should be stored in the
refrigerator most brands state that the
milk should
be used within seven to ten days of
opening i do not abide by that almond
milk rule
the seven to ten days is is a is a it's
a
it's a large crock of horseshit sal i
gotta be honest with you
uh the almond milk that i'm currently
drinking right now at home
four months usually i cannot believe
that it's seven to ten days
it tastes fine 120 days opened easily
open
open and outside next to the
refrigerator i actually keep my milk as
next to my toaster oven wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute
you are drinking four-month-old
non-refrigerated almond milk
and that's why you're putting ice cubes
in it well it's yeah but but but
but it's not we only opened up we have a
sharp plus of almond milk the kids love
almond milk
lactose intolerant family right the the
almond milk that we have that's
four months old has been unopened out of
the
you know out like okay but i opened up
that almond milk because i just went to
facebook and they just keep it outside
front
but i opened up that almond milk eight
or nine days ago
that's not good i i i wonder what does
complain of stomach
there was one time i had almond milk and
i was like oh that tastes not like
almond milk
and i must have had it uh you know like
a couple of months in the fridge
after i opened it and that was no good
but but largely i'll drink almond milk
what did it taste like
what did it taste like no good there was
like a weird lingering aftertaste
see i can power through that stuff oh
did i tell you i ate straight up mold
the other day
yes you did you told you you told and
then but but you said you're fine
disgusting
disgusting right yeah because i was like
this tastes very peculiar and i looked
down and the whole package was like
green but you never got sick i didn't
that's why i don't think the raw pork is
going to take you down i think you've
got a strong stomach
okay but i think the raw pork is
different yeah well i'll tell you what's
different is goat cheese
i don't want that at all ever again in
my life dude babes yep
we are in the thick of 2020's ugly
sequel and guess what life can still be
stressful as
f yeah i mean if you're feeling that
existential dread whenever you have a
couple of minutes of downtime
you might be experiencing those scary
luckily our partners at sunday scaries
make the best f and c we need products
to turn those wts into lols
forget about an old awkward date or that
time you responded to a server telling
you to enjoy your meal
with a good old you too sunday scaries
is here to provide you the remedy to
make life not so scary their cbd
gummies are so perfect they're the
perfect product to help you kick back
and chill
the f out they even added vitamins b12
and d3 to get that extra boost of
vitamin goodness to give you the perfect
blend to make you more tolerable to your
co-workers and friends
babe can i ask you a question yeah you
vegan no
sunday scaries even has vegan gummies
called vegan af
that are the guilt-free version of cbd
you've been kindly hunting
to help you forget about becky's
showboat ig account
don't get shook in 2021 get 20
off at sundayscaries.com and use the
promo code hey babe
20 off at sundayscares.com with promo
code hey babe
it's 20 off at sundayscaries.com with
the promo code hey babe
thanks sunday scares for making sundays
chill again
i've really the last like couple of
weeks i've been really having like a
rock hard penis
for most of the day interesting because
i've been using bluetooth
i've been using because i had those
problems when i i couldn't get my penis
up and nothing i do
just my dick would it just wouldn't go
up but now i've been going to
bluechew.com and i put in the promo code
hey babe
and i've been getting it for free no
that's
not nothing in this life is free well
you get five dollars off
shipping no that's not true at all you
spend five dollars for shipping
and you get it for free you spend five
dollars i was setting you up to be like
no there is things in life that you get
for free
and then i thought you were going to hit
them with the great deal that we have
for them but
we floundered and we're not going to
edit this out because we're men of the
people because women are the people and
i'm proud to stand by my erection
and if you just go to bluetooth.com
promo code hey
you get your first shipment free and and
then you just pay
five beans for the shipping that's it so
you're paying for the shipping you're
getting the product for free you can't
beat that you can't beat
think about the the ads we do 10 off 20
off
no this is that the other this is free
free promo code hey babe pay 5
shipping bluetooth.com that's it i can't
believe how
how truly sick to my stuff i really do
enjoy it so i was in i was in
i was on the road right and i ordered
like uh i had to
use the per diem and it was like it was
like 50 bucks or whatever it is night
i charged a bunch of i remember it came
after 77 so i went 27 bucks above the
per diem
it was like a salad a quesadilla maybe
like a piece of cheesecake
right and like a pitcher of tea or
something like that right and i remember
i was so dead tired and i
i ordered the food and i ordered until i
ordered a hot tub time machine
on the on the
so the food comes and the way i eat food
in the hotel is
i'll push the little tray like the
little table to the edge of the bed
okay so usually hopefully the heights
align and then if i need to i'll open it
so you'll scoot all the way to the edge
of the bed
i'll lay on my stomach right so the tv
is there the bed is here
so i'll lay on my stomach feet up like a
16 year old girl like myself you're a
girl in 70s
yeah so i'm on my stomach and i'm
watching the television
and then i push the table right up to
the edge of the bed smaller
but sometimes it is a height
differential and i open up
a nice big towel okay i open it across
the foot of the bed
and then i make like the towel is my
table top
and then i take everything off the table
i arrange it across the bed
and i and i lay there and i eat in the
bed now
i say it and it also sounds terrible
that i'm doing that it sounds weird like
i don't know you're in a mattress you're
with your linens and you're eating
like i'm cutting a pour you know right
so so it is weird
but there really is no other way to do
it on the road on the right now hotel i
think the rules go out the window don't
you think oh yeah 100 like you do
anything and i'll eat
i'll eat the food you know in the shower
or something 100 i do
yeah i'll i i think yeah because because
things in a hotel they're your
you know it feels like home but it's not
home it's like you got the bed the tv
the shower
but you know they're really not your
things it's not your thing so it's just
like
you kind of like you know there's been
times where like here's the thing
there's been times where i've been
inadvertently so disgusting in a hotel
that i think about now like
what is like who are the people in this
hotel because i saw once
in the hotel i didn't know people did
that i didn't know that the housekeeping
staff did
this and granted the hotel i was staying
out wasn't very nice
but i saw them in the room next to me
go in i saw the guy come out it was
quick and then they went in
and i i went and got ice and i came back
and i saw them put there's no way they
could have changed
all the sheets they just put the sheets
back up and sprayed down the sheets
with some kind of spray yeah they did
not change the sheets at all wow
so like it might be illegal up to it
well i mean that's what happens when you
say it in a ramada
is it was it a ramana shout out romano
shout out ramada good company if they
want to sponsor
i uh i i remember i i put everything to
the edge of the bed
and then i i swear to god i woke up
and i must have laid everything out i
was dead tired i ordered the movie
and i woke up i don't know how long it
was later but it was more than two hours
because i woke up and my i opened my
eyes
and my face was on the quesadilla
i had not eaten the quesadilla yet it
was like a circle tortilla pillow my
face was laying in it
yeah because i put it right here i guess
and i just kind of like dozed and hit it
and i woke up nothing was touched i
lifted my face
off the quesadilla and i looked at the
screen and said thank you for ordering
hot tub time machine
on the thing which is kind of like
it was like i time-warped you know like
i'm like i didn't watch that movie at
all but did you eat the quesadilla it
didn't
went to bed it was 77 i didn't touch
anything you didn't need a single
yeah have you ever eaten food off
somebody else's plate
you ever done that like been drunk
coming home from a hotel they got the
food out and let's say french fries are
out because a lot of people don't eat
all their french fries you ever eaten a
french fry off the plate
drunk yeah you have right i i
i don't do it often i only done it once
i think it wasn't a french fry but
speaking of quesadilla i was it with me
and q we were in
uh new orleans it was a long time ago
i've been to new orleans
yeah never been in that city well for
some reason it was hard to find food
at like two in the morning we were
staying in like the sheridan or
something there was no room service
there's no bodegas and nothing was
delivering there was no food to be found
we were bombed going back to our rooms
like what are we gonna do
and there was someone's room service
tray out
and we lifted up the thing and it was a
quesadilla that two
two of the triangles were eaten from it
okay and the rest weren't
wow and i am a i am not one that really
would ever do that i'm a germ guy right
and i i was drunk and i hate i hate
someone saying i hate someone's
discarded
his case that's the same new orleans
trip where you had no voice and you had
a show in front of pac people because i
was thinking if it was i know that right
you have no
no that was no this was like 10 years
ago that was like two three years
he had a show once pimp where he had
like sold out thousand people
plus he had no voice he was talking like
this oh my god like he was talking like
like he got the throat surgery yeah
we had the cruise in new orleans and we
docked there and then i did a show at
the joy theater
it was actually me i don't know it was
me nate
burt i think cypher because everybody
was there
i think i think louis was he was all i
couldn't talk
this was this was the loudest i could
talk
and so i went out in the beginning and i
said this is the loudest i could talk
i was like i don't think i'm gonna do
the show and everyone's like just do it
i'm like you don't understand this is
gonna get annoying
yeah and they were like just do it go
you know i would go so i went backstage
in the show and i was like all right at
the end of the show if i if i'm i'll see
what happens
and i think everybody told you this but
i swear to god i'm backstage i don't
know what to do
actually who it was everyone on the
cruise came and hung out
and yamaneka was there giannis was
actually saunders yeah so yamaneka felt
so bad for me
and she made this concoction i was
drinking honey tea
lozenges any i was in the back just
gargling rubbing my throat
just hoping that somebody would come
back within like 45 minutes
where i can get up and do my set at the
end and god bless yamaneka i don't know
what she did she she made some elixir
she made me drank drink it
then she came back she took me by the
throat and she
was massaging my throat and like saying
like prayers for me
right it was the coolest thing
i got to a place where i was able to
talk like this and i went out and i did
i did 30 minutes talking like this jesus
yeah i have
i actually have that set on on tape
somewhere i have it it's
audio only but i could probably play it
and you could hear it yeah and you could
just hear it i can't i felt so bad but
my whole family was there
and you know what my family had never
seen me perform before but since they
were on the cruise
they were like oh we'll come to the show
and it was the first time i extended
family my parents sisters cousins aunts
my grandma everything yeah
and i was talking like that you were
trying and you and you just like had to
do like your bits
i felt terrible yeah but you had to get
it through i know dude that's
literally i once was performing in
houston
texas and they i mean i don't have to
say texas you know we're used to yes
what am i i'm not pouring on whitney
houston i was thinking that about that
when you said it but i just like that's
where it's like you know i'm performing
oklahoma city oklahoma
yeah um so um i'm
doing the show the first show then in
between shows we decide to
we had an hour to kill decided to go to
this burger place i get a burger and a
beer and truffle fries
second show saturday night i literally
dude
i literally i'm like i'm to throw like
food poisoning
like throw up like people are coming up
to me and i'm just like i can't like
shake kills yeah sergio chico and the
great surgery corners open it for me
is in the green room or in the back
loading dock where i'm like
please get me pepto like whatever like
i'm i'm literally throwing up
he's in the back with me you know trying
to help me out while he's smoking a
cigarette blowing he's like
he's like yo bob it's gonna pass bob you
only got 45 minutes pop and he's like
blowing cigarette smoke in my face
the great sergio chicone shot him out
and and i'm like dude this isn't helping
he goes you can get through a pop so i
throw up all over
like all over i had to go on stage in
houston
with the garbage pail yeah the
adrenaline kicked in
for the first 25 minutes and i'm like it
went down
yeah 28 29 minutes at the show i threw
up into the side of the bucket
came back kept doing the set i got to
42 43 minutes on the dot got right off
threw up for the rest of the night and
then
it was like legit food poisoning where
and now to this day to this day
i do not eat any type of meat or drink
beer or
anything or eat heavy at all before show
i won't do it i'd rather throw up
after the show everything about eating
before show
is bad even if the worst thing that
happens is you're tired or sluggish
right i hate eating before a show won't
do it but yeah i've done
those shows where i've had to like just
keep going to the side throwing up and
coming back on
really yeah yeah i did that if you say
that casually a few times
yeah did you go to the doctor for that
no no i mean like in different times
like not the same weekend you know but
i'm saying like i've been to a comedy
ten years it's time for me once you've
happened to me twice
okay but i felt like where i actually
threw up and threw up into a bucket and
right during the show
there's been times where i threw up
right before the show and then not again
until after the show
but what what's the reason do you just
have a sense of stomach was it nerves no
i had a virus i was sick i was pretty
sick
yeah but no yeah but then oh god dude
and if you have to like
hold it if you're in the middle of a
joke and you can't think of anything but
your entire body is shaking trembling
cold sweats and you're like trying to do
this with your own you're like
if i make one wrong move i'm gonna just
everything in my body is gonna explode
right it's the it's so it's the worst
feeling
in the world yeah and you can't shake it
or if you and or if it's like
show one and then it doesn't go away
before show two
yeah i can't think of a situation that
outside of like something ridiculous
like being on the front lines of a war
or something
i in general real life i can't think of
a situation i
i'd more not want to be in than that
it was so terrifying to like think about
like
[ __ ] i got to do 45 minutes to an hour
these people don't care that i'm sick
they paid they're all looking up at me
burning hot lights
sweating and you feel like you're gonna
throw up like you feel
like so nauseous that all you want to do
is lay down with all the lights off and
you have to now
60 minutes think about how long that is
of performing making things up as you go
along being in the moment writing jokes
terrifying terrifying terrifying
terrifying when i was in third grade
thomas fleshbow what's his name he
flespo thomas falesbo filespo flespo
always has been always will be thomas
westbow is i've never heard that last
name
kid's a unique kid and you've probably
never heard of what he's you've probably
never heard of anyone doing what he did
okay thomas flespo he's got a stomach
virus in the back of class is
embarrassed doesn't want to tell anybody
that he's got a stomach virus i guess
feels like he's going to hurl i'm you
know he's sitting in
you know the middle role i'm sitting in
the row next to him i'm looking up you
know like at the teacher
mrs mcnevin shout out she's a nice lady
um she's doing you know a subject you
know whatever she's doing
and i look over and he oh my book bag
was open with my books and he throws up
into my book bag just
yours fully vomits into my book bag
flesbo
fless both fully vomits into my book bag
then zips it back up
yeah i swear to god he at the time was
doing karate so like a little kid that
does karate like beat the [ __ ] out of
you
he says don't tell anyone about this
don't say a word about he used his belt
against
him his belt against me so now i have a
book bag full of
somebody else's vomit we get out you
know the nerve of flesh power swear to
god we get out we
we get out you know an hour later i go
home my mother opens up my book bag
that's had it's now it's now marinating
in vomit yeah well she said and again
because i didn't want to write off less
bow because he's
you know first degree black belt in
third grade she goes oh my god honey
there's vomit all in your book pick i
was like i know i threw up i got sick
and she's like really i said yeah and
then she's like oh my god oh my god she
goes okay well we're going to stay home
from school tomorrow
i was like absolutely we are whoa so i
got off from school and then she wanted
she woke me up that morning and was like
how are you feeling today
do you still have stomach pains and i
said yeah kind of and then she went to
the bathroom and i went
to my refrigerator and i got lemonade
which was in the pitcher because she
always had this basin that people would
throw up until my mom had like a puke
bucket
and once she was in the bathroom well
you know because she could hear me in
earshot i poured the lemonade
into the bucket and went yeah as if i
was puking
and then i said that i was like mom this
puke is really gross i'm going to go
flush it down the sink
and then i poured the lemonade into the
sink and got a full day off at school
karate bully yeah the cobra kai i have a
question
yes have you ever [ __ ] yourself on stage
i feel like you would
on no i've never shut myself on stage
but what did happen was
is i one time was performing i want to
say in pittsburgh
and some a guy threw
shart stained underwear at onto the
stage
he throws him up he somebody said
something and then all of a sudden a
pair of
fake or real real a pair of underwear
that's a crime
come throwing onto the stage and i'm so
like did somebody throw their underwear
and there was a huge short stain
no i swear to god oh i would hurl
immediately yeah and it got
i would actually be very very upset no i
was one of those guys where like i got
like a big laugh
immediately and i just like threw it to
the back and just was like so i was on
the subway today
oh my gosh i went right more into more
bits but that's the only [ __ ]
story i've never i've never [ __ ] on
today i've had to
to be honest with you performing live
performing what i've noticed is if i
really have to go to the bathroom number
one or two or three
i just keep it in if it's really urgent
i actually keep it in
and i don't do it until after my set
because it keeps me in the moment
it keeps me very present with my
material and the audience to know that i
i'm gonna
absolutely destroy a toilet as soon as i
put the mic
back in the stand yeah yeah can you do
that too or you have to get it out
well i wouldn't leave stage i don't
think speaking of poop
oh yeah i get a little surprise for you
baby wow baloney
that's another thing that he hasn't had
he hasn't had baloney
baloney uh i mean i think bologna is
um a mixture of many different
beefs and meats and parts
of animals i think as long as it does
talk about this before but i think
bologna has hooves in it
hooves hooves like jello hooves hoops
okay does it have goat cheese is it a
hoove
h-o-o-v-e-s hooves who's a hooves
behooves you
behooves you no it's behoove but
i think i think there might be like you
know even like all different
parts in here but
let's start what i was going to tell you
earlier which was something else and now
i'm completely
something about fless bow what is
bologna made of it's a cooked smoked
sausage made of cured beef cured pork
or a mixture of the two bologna might
include choice cuts depending on who's
making it but usually contains
afterthoughts of the meat industry
organs trimmings and end pieces and so
on so the bologna
bologna contains afterthoughts of the
meat industry
organs trimmings which i don't like that
what is a trimming
uh what is this a christmas tree
trimmings
and what was the other thing
organs and end pieces
so what is that have you ever had
bologna oh yeah
no it sounds disgusting but you'll eat
this bologna and
you know if you had it on cheese with
cheese on a piece of bread
i can't eat cold cheese
i'm sorry go go take the whole thing
it's for you
god bless you it's a quarter pound
oh even this is a perfect circle
yeah i don't think baloney's that bad
you got to keep an open mind
and usually you again usually you'd have
i wouldn't
not only is this my first piece of
baloney i'm being honest with you sal
i think this is my first cold cut in
general
maybe since before 9 11.
i don't think i've had a cold cut since
9 11. are you serious i swear we haven't
eaten processed
meats for 20 years not call cuts wow
i don't think i've had a cold cut since
pre-911 why so i feel like i'm letting
the terrorists win when i do this
really yeah all right
i mean no baloney's not too bad buddy
it's gonna taste like uh somewhere in
between uh
this into that like a ham and a
bologna doesn't smell terrific smells
actually like my dad's cologne
it smells like i smell like a smoky vibe
yeah okay okay i i don't know what
trimmings and end pieces mean
my i remember my a kid i went to school
with richie sixth grade said
said he would always have bologna and
ketchup sandwiches and they taste like
hot dogs
is that true okay i could kind of i
could maybe kind of see that a little
bit actually
because bologna it does taste like a hot
dog so that's what we said before
remember when you threw up in school
when you were younger
yeah and all they did was come in and
put wood chips on us yeah like that was
okay
it wasn't like a disinfectant there
wasn't a it wasn't like a mop
there wasn't even a mop involved no soap
and water was not involved it can't
throw up everywhere no it was this huge
mound of throat
they came and put sawdust on it sawdust
it let it
soak into the soils and he would come
and brush it with a broom and a dust pan
yeah they would just throw it on there
and said listen
i know you just puked but now this is a
carpet oh it's like vomit chips yeah
that's the vomit chips
now we're at mcsorely house how is that
okay i don't know i don't know dude i
don't know but the rules were different
pre-911
what do schools use to clean up vomit
whereas the sawdust and cat litter will
help
to clump the vomit together and make it
easier to remove from the surfaces while
also offering some of
sort of deodorization of the odors
emitted from these bodily fluids in the
environment by the way is there a more
disgusting word than
clump clump oh yeah you have a clump on
your neck
especially a a saw dusty clump of vomit
i'm gonna eat this clump of balloon
i've never had bologna in my life so
it's a bunch of firsts today
first time pork chop which i loved first
time goat cheese which i
hated sal first time cinnabon which he
loved
now for the baloney the finishing touch
let's do do i have to eat the whole
thing or take a bite what do you think i
would eat the whole thing i was also
going to say but maybe
i wouldn't be able to convince you to
put goat cheese in the bologna
no you already he already hates the goat
cheese let's let's judge the bolognese
just keep an open mind again it's not
supposed to be the best meat but i don't
think it's that gross
i can't feel it really it's that bad it
is
you know just eating straight bologna
especially after you've had a pork chop
and a cinnabon
yeah it's
[Laughter]
wow i'm getting a little nauseous now i
can't look at it
you have to cover that up oh god
i can't i can't continue to look at that
bologna i can't continue to look at the
half-eaten bologna
oh this has been hey baby
oh man i i i i okay okay
i i no no no no no no no no no no no i i
will i will get killed i will get closer
i'm being honest man that i i may like
i'm going to throw up on the virus on a
bridge yeah i hated the baloney
oh all right it's hard to shake the
taste once you have it
all right i got i also have another
podcast uh called chrissy chaos
uh follow me there uh christy comedy.com
uh chrissychaos comes out at 11am
eastern time patreon.com slash christy
comedy
um and i got a lot of stand up dates
coming up uh so check me out
okay and then check out taste buds or
other podcasts on the no pressure
network
and then hit me up on my community app
my phone number seven one eight
two six zero six six one nine i text you
guys back and whatnot
and uh oh i'm on tick tock now
i haven't really been done anything yet
but i'm on it great tick tick tock's
awesome yeah
hit me up on tick-tock is that what they
do tick-tock get it out hit salad baby
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away
from your feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey